as I bet you potatoes before right we're
not so focused on what these are
actually equal to so much as or how low
do you get me what's the process what's
that what's the reason behind 2.72 as
opposed to 2.718 okay so someone talk me
through what were you thinking as you
went to write down number one so I wanna
know and tell me how they were that what
did you look at what we okay so you're
looking at which figures are significant
in other words the biggest in this
context so you went for the third one
one two three which is that guy why are
we looking at battlebot because it's the
one that they possibly think right it's
the other one will go up or stay the
rest of the numbers two and seven
clearly go stay put so we've come up
with two point seven two why is that
okay cuz it's the nutbar it's the number
directly after it which means okay two
point seven three will be closer than
two point seven one happy how about this
one I think most people are okay with
this how do you get this no bus what do
you get from yeah yeah another way of
thinking about it like this is exactly
right when you keep counting one two
three four five even these aren't zeros
right
what's your you know changing your
number here your x that would make it
that much bigger okay
so in some ways because you always want
the number between one and ten you're
just kind of looking at this first digit
and everything else would be kind of
sweet food as zeros when you're
multiplying by that okay and they're
fine perfect conversion call mr. Semyon
is what are we multiplying by in this
case mayor should ask a question flap
why are we multiplying enough divided
why are you multiplying
okay so we go to the smaller units and
these units are tiny so to be equivalent
you're gonna have lots of them that's
make sense that's why this number is so
large okay what was that
okay so you multiply by a thousand to
turn that into meters and you got to go
again to temp 2 centimeters so there's
two steps you gotta go happy times this
one multiplication or division oh yes so
here we come back to you meet as in like
how do i oh just put those together tell
me yeah short answer is yes you can't
because times a thousand times 100 is
times 100,000 so that's fun however I do
like it kind of doing it like this
because this shows to me I'll look
they're actually two steps that I climb
down the ladder so I have my two steps
there and of course the calculator will
take care of the rest for us okay so I'm
happy with that but I still like this
one here we are getting to really begin
if there's a B right so what did we
divide by in this case it's 10,000 right
because in hectare is a square that's
100 meters by 100 meters and that gives
you the 10,000 which is what you divided
by right and then lastly I think we I
mean liters and bills are very very good
stuff